this is a production of cornell
university
here this is called protect your bald
head hat is what this
is so what we're going to do
mike brown who is my
this guy is the best research support
specialist
thank you certainly in new york state
possibly in the northeast
uh mike has been really my right-hand
man for
what 12 years 13 years
and greg was also involved in and quite
a bit of the work that we're going to
look at so i want them both to come with
me
and um we're going to just do a quick
walk through
because it doesn't look like it's going
to rain
we're going to go through the orchard up
here and greg i'm hoping you can talk
since this is greg's phd
and then we'll swing through and i'll
talk a little bit about apple replant
work and and then we'll probably come
back so we're just gonna
it's full bloom we gotta have an excuse
to walk in the orchard so let's go
this way
so this was uh greg's phd
planning so i'm gonna i want greg to do
most of talking
a little bit of the history of it uh
this is liberty which is
a lot of people consider it the most
disease-resistant apple that's ever been
developed it's a cornell
apple uh has mccown and a bunch of other
stuff in its parentage and uh
rick risinger rick's not here but he was
a really key person that i worked with
during the 90s most of the trees that
you see
except for those i think rick planted it
was fabulous having an orchard manager
who was as much of a fanatic as i was
about planning new stuff
and and seeing how it did so we planted
this in 1994
just because we wanted to have some scab
immune stuff here
and uh to work with so greg why don't
you
tell us about this sure you got a holler
so this is a whole plot it's about um
about an acre or so it's all liberty on
m9 a dwarfing rootstock
and it was planted here for different
purposes and actually uh
the summer before i came in ian had two
undergraduate students
emily vollmer and christine avril
started on a project here looking at
organic systems and
integrated fruit production which is the
conventional system in europe um to the
state really which is a low input
soft uh program integrating uh
insect control and nutrient management
and water management into a system and
so
the goal of the project was to really
look at can we do organic
here in the northeast which is very
difficult with the large
pest complex that we have 50 some odd
arthropod pests and another
20 different fungi and bacteria and
other
other disease agents that that really
are uh
difficult to control even the
conventional system but can we do an
organic system and also let's look at
this european system this ifp
system so we had four replications of
each of the treatments
in this plot here and i ran the study
for we had four years of data on it
and looked at everything from soil
ecology
through productivity of the trees fruit
quality
nutraceutical content of the fruit
consumer sensory panels
environmental impacts it was a very
holistic sort of project
and we saw wrote the publication that
ian showed as well out of the
out of the organic side of the work here
long and short of it is that
yeah you can do organic if the premium
is high enough to get the return on
investment
which is required for the additional
pest pest control practices that you
need to do
and the loss of fruit somewhat smaller
fruit size that you get
and the additional hand labor but um but
it's doable and it's an economic
question more than a
than a feasibility question even with
that though
hasn't really taken off we were hoping
you know maybe some people would be
interested in
i know anecdotally there's some still
some experimentation with organic
in the northeast but we'll see where the
future is
the ifp system has largely been
incorporated into new systems such as
the gap
the uh
cultural practices uh systems that are
now that the supermarkets the retailers
are really requiring for the growers so
slowly that's becoming the standard here
as it as it has in europe as well
so um yeah i spent a lot of time out
here it's probably the most micromanaged
organic plots in
in the northeast at the time and is it
still being managed organically
is actually the whole block is now
down to the edge and we have the nothing
eric inspector here
when was that eric a year ago about and
they looked at it and basically said no
problem if you want to certify it
this is one of the few organic
comparisons with other systems that was
actually replicated
uh instead of pseudo-replicated where
you're comparing this farm to that farm
and it actually worked really well i
think it was a good experimental design
that we had set here
so this is the only planning i've ever
managed
that i've gotten a call from
environmental health and safety and said
what the hell are you guys doing out
there it smells like there's a bunch of
dead fish
and that's because the thinning
treatment that we use here
is lime sulfur and crocker's fish oil
and it it's uh if you've driven in here
in the summer
this whole thing is whitewashed that's
the surround very effective organic
insect repellent and the thinning that
we do
is lime sulfur was combination of dead
fish and rotten eggs it's great stuff to
work with
i describe it as jersey shore and
apologies to those who were from the
jersey shore
but uh it smells like that just
coincidentally and every year it turned
out this way and i didn't do it on
purpose but it always turned out i had
to put that application on a
commencement weekend
i don't know it just turned out that way
yeah i'm i you know i'm a believer in
quitting while you're ahead
hey taryn
i want you to talk about your root boxes
just a little bit you got a holler oh
man
i'll stand i'll stand here okay we can
i wish well i wish we had one open um
so well these are root boxes as ian
mentioned they are basically um if we
could pull the lid off of
one of these what you would find inside
is basically
uh mylar sheets on each side
of these root boxes so that we can
actually observe
the roots growing against them over time
the problem with apples is that
unlike almost every other tree crop
plant i've ever worked with they have
such a minimal root system
compared comparatively and so we have a
really actually difficult time
finding roots on these trees and so
these are installed about a year ago
or so now but it'll be exciting this
spring to open them up and
and see what we found um last year when
we checked them there was hardly
anything there and it was somewhat
disappointing but
fingers across for this year and
hopefully we'll find something are they
worse than grapes
much worse grapes have like 10 times as
many roots
the poster child
yeah we had i think we had uh
60 observation to how many do we have
out here mike when we had the rhizotron
tubes
was it 60. and uh
the work when shangri was coming doing
weekly observations
i think we only ended up with something
like 80 roots and the whole damn orchard
that happened to be next to the tube
i mean you actually made me kind of
nervous when the wind blows i think
the orchard's just going to blow away
because they don't have much of a root
system
sometimes i'm amazed at how apples uh
do it with such a minimal root system i
don't it's amazing yeah they must be
incredibly mycorrhizal with all i can
say yeah yeah and the roots
are steady the ones they do have are
pretty active i think
yes
uh this the question was what's the root
stock
there's six different root stocks here
so this is the replant experiment that i
was talking about in there
the old tree rows went this way and
the pre-plant treatments went this way
and they're blocked
five times from east to west
and then the so there were four
pre-plant treatments you remember
blocked
wrapped five times by the blocks and
then each tree
basically is they've all got well most
of them still have tags
they it's a each tree is a replica
of the factorial combination so
and it's been pretty stunning uh the
differences
even now i mean that that even after
what
10 years i guess right it was 2001 when
we actually planted these trees
they just they're not converging at all
and usually in a replant study
where people have looked at fumigation
as a treatment
you get this big difference for three or
four years
where the trees in fumigated ground are
just bigger and more productive
and then after about 10 years they kind
of come together and that has not
happened with these rootstocks
so it's pretty amazing yeah this was for
me
for 20 years you know i would work on
replant and it was all totally empirical
we'd do something
and then we'd come back and we'd measure
how the trees grew or how much fruit
they produced or how much
nitrogen they took up and this was the
first time we ever said you know what i
want to know
why are they doing what they're doing it
was really the one of the first
mechanistic and it was great being able
to work with janice
and having grad students you know greg
also
did a fair amount of molecular work and
the liberty there
for me it was a it was a big step to
just sort of make that transition to
i used to be one of those somewhat of a
luddite i guess
where you know we all used to make nasty
remarks about molecular biologists and
you know how they weren't doing anything
useful but it's
i've really come to realize that was
pretty stupid because the truth is
it's just they're just techniques and
they're incredibly powerful techniques
that you can apply in agricultural
systems
that enable you to understand what's
what's happening why it's happening how
it's happening it's
it's really powerful stuff so if you're
a student
and you think oh this is not my cup of
tea
i always great can the test and i told
my students you're going to learn how to
apply this
these techniques while you're here
because you're it's crazy if you don't
so
most orientalists let's keep so they
could
walking
uh used in breeding groups oh yeah
yeah i mean we published that all that
stuff
threatened to lie down in front of the
bulldozer when our
our various people wanted to get rid of
these trees over the years these are the
oldest trees in the whole orchard
19 actually we don't know the truth of
the matter is we didn't keep very good
records in this orchard
we don't even know exactly when the
first trees were planted here we think
it was around 1908 or 1909
but these trees are probably from the
early 1920s
i suppose where's ken some
we need a dendrochronologist out here
actually to to take something
from before take a core and tell us
exactly when these trees were planted so
we we keep them around the the guys in
the crew understandably or
it's a lot of work i actually used to
prune these with my orchard management
class
until the risk assessment people said
you know maybe
you shouldn't have students on 18 foot
ladders with chainsaws you know that's
not quite
um but it's it's uh i love having them
here because this this is kind of the
history of the apple
and it's really good for students to be
able to show them
this is what orchards look like 40 by 40
feet
uh and the other remarkable thing i mean
look at the bloom this tree is almost
100 years old and it's just raring to go
so hope springs eternal this is a good
thing to look at when you're about to
retire here right
now these are all grafted on ceiling
roots
and they're cortlands they're these may
be the oldest living
cortland trees
before it was a name variety yeah
and cortland uh for those who aren't
familiar it's a cornell apple
one of the earliest introductions of the
geneva
apple breeding program mccown and
cortland were right back there about the
same era early 1900s
i think 1923 was when kirtland was named
if i remember correctly
so we'll quickly walk through here
justine
so i want justine to talk a little bit
about this this vineyard
what would you like to do just tell us
tell us why it's here what do we do with
it all right so
uh this is one of our teaching vineyards
and we call it the pool block named
after bob poole who was a viticulturist
he was my favorite viticulture geneva
who uh who designed this uh and so
there's a real
mix of stuff um through here at the at
the very far end and i'm suggesting
we're gonna walk that way
there's actually the geneva double
curtain which is a
very good training system that that came
out of uh research at geneva by nelson
charlotte
where he divided the canopy he did all
the research down in fredonia and those
people are upset
that it is called the geneva double
curtain and not the fredonia double
curtains
and seriously it is a difficult topic
down there um
but it was uh then widely used by the
concord industry for a long time and for
is starting to fall out of favor now
uh and then he put in a a rotational
program so that
students could work with a very young
vine so we've got concord and cybal
that range from zero to five years uh
and then some uh different uh thousands
of vines and
perfume versus killing pruned we've got
some of
what at the time were bruce's grueling
selections
but are now named cultivars so there's
some coral noir
uh through here which was was the
um the seventy number right the new york
seven blue
um plus some older just shown act 2 for
just shonak one thing we do
and and uh and steve lerch does a lot of
the the working here for teaching
purposes
is we'll prune the show next to zero
node so no nodes at all so it
technically shouldn't have any yield
but that crazy felt bar will go six
times in over on zero uh
zero nodes because it's really really
fruitful from the latent bud
uh and then there's a a whole selection
of table groves
uh which era some guys took care of and
then uh harvest themselves here
at this store um beautiful beautiful
grapes most of them from
uh the cornell brewing program stuff
like mindset foodless uh is a popular
one in canada
too um so that's what we basically have
in
in this block we've got a couple other
uh teaching blocks one up on the
that we call the hilltop block that uh
ian actually planted
and then next to that is a an organic
block actually certified by nofa new
york
um that ian and i and kathy arnick are
enology lecturer who's here somewhere oh
they're here
um that we planted and we use for a
class there
so i find it my bob poole was
my nemesis when i decided i wanted to
get involved in
viticulture i said well what can i
contribute i said probably i can help
get some vineyards established because
we had none
and i called bob pool up and said bob
will you tell me what varieties you want
and i want to try to get some plantings
established for this new program we're
developing and he said merwin you will
do that over my dead body
and he was furious because he saw
viticulture was geneva's thing and he
did not want ithaca to have any of that
action
so so we named the block after him just
this poetic justice i guess right
so but here it is and uh for that's been
great for me the last 10 years i guess
it has been now
i'd gotten to a point in my apple
research where i kind of
accomplished a lot of what i wanted to i
figure i got another 10 good years
what can i do that'll make a difference
and uh it's been
it's been really fabulous we got to hire
all these great viticulture people we
got to hire kathy to teach
and i think we've got a really quality
program that's
still in the building and of course now
we're looking for another person will be
primarily a viticulturist
to uh to fill the line that i used to
have so
and for any home wine makers out there
we do sell
all the grapes from our student
vineyards um and we can actually press
them here for you and you can have the
juice so you can either have grapes or
have the juice
um so if you're interested keep us in
mind in the fall
and bruce did you get to try the cider
that was in there
no didn't make it over there the uh
i was amazed how fast it went i must
confess it was it was two gallons of
cider that just vaporized but
uh the red color for those of you that
did try it
actually was noire i had some noire
that i nobody wanted to buy it and i was
looking at it it was kind of starting to
raise it in my cooler and
said well you know i'm going to throw
that in the cider and just see what it
does it has
it's a really spicy grape with lots of
color
and i thought it might give the cider
some color and there is just a little
touch in ra that if you know what the
grape smells like
do you think it's detectable right um
so that was fun i think i'm gonna do it
again i'm not sure i use an ra i might
use something that
not quite as pungent but we can sell you
something
yeah i'm sure you can
all right so i think we should probably
head back
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu